it's sad that we're gonna lose species
forever because once a species got an
asset extinction is forever you know
that's it you're out of the gene pool
it's usually a senseless you know people
killing rhinos for their horns which is
keratin as hair there's got no medical
properties whatsoever even if it did
have medical properties they better be
pretty good and you still don't have to
slaughter thing and rip its horn out
what it's got a car
ivory same for a trinket you can in this
magnificent animal for a trinket there's
no point also this nonsense they people
say no its conservation we're doing good
they're not doing good they like to kill
things if it was providing the service
we'd be paying them that doesn't say can
I pay you some money to shoot your cat
with a bow an hour and then take a
selfie with it they're Psychopaths they
like shooting things it's an absolute
nonsense they like killing things they
like killing it with different weaponry
they like it indifferent and they're
willing to pay for the fun of shooting
someone imagine if I went into a cancer
ward and said can I kill one of them but
I'll give a million pounds to all the
others to cure cancer you go [ __ ] off
your psychopath so it's bollocks it's
not conservation it's rich psychos who
liked killing things [ __ ]
[Music]